I think you guys are going to like this
one Donald Trump and everybody around
him are denying knowing this guy love
Parnas and they're all ending up in
pictures with left Parnas that are
leaking very quickly the name Lev Parnas
has become a pretty important name in
the Trump Ukraine fiasco not yet a
household name but maybe soon I'll
remind you that sort of chain of command
Donald Trump hired Rudy Giuliani as his
personal attorney one of the things that
Rudy Giuliani did was get ambassador
Murray Ivanovic quote out of the way for
Donald Trump that's the way Rudy put it
when he was interviewed recently and the
way that Rudy Giuliani partially got
Murray Ivanovic out of the way
was with the help of two henchmen left
partes and Igor Froman both have since
been indicted crewman is not visibly
cooperating Lev Parnas visibly very much
cooperating with documents and files and
recordings and all sorts of stuff and
for a while Republicans have been saying
we don't know the guy we have no idea
who this guy is
more recently documents revealed that
Lev Parnas was involved in putting
physical surveillance on Murray
Ivanovich in Ukraine he did an interview
with Rachel Maddow saying everyone
around Trump knew what it was that was
going on pence everybody knew it was
also confirmed as I told you last week
that despite Devon knew necess denials
left Parnas and Devon Nunez did
communicate by phone
Devon newness miraculously remembering
that last week as loved Parnas release
documents so now everybody around Trump
is panicked and they're immediately
scrambling to save left partner I don't
I don't know the guy no idea who you're
talking about so let's go through it
step by step and dig into the brazen and
bold nature of the lies that they are
telling you here's Donald Trump himself
saying I don't know the guy thank you
question what is your response
you're referencing your frame we're all
about 20/20 you just wanted to go by now
I don't know him
I don't know harness other than I guess
I had pictures taken which I do with
thousands of people including people
today that I didn't meet but just met
him and as Trump mentions yes there are
pictures here is a picture of Donald
Trump with left Parnas back in 2014 and
as Donald Trump says this is not proof
that anything more than a picture with a
random person was taken but it's a
little different than oh do you know
this body shop owner in Missoula no well
here's a picture of you with him when
you went to a rally in Missoula okay
yeah well I met him when swinging
through because it just so happens that
we have another picture with Trump and
Parnas and Parnas with Ivanka and Parnas
with Jared Kushner and partners with
Trump adviser Kellyanne Conway and
Parnas with Vice President Mike Pence
and Parnas with Donald Trump jr. and
Parnas with Eric Trump and on and on and
on but there's even more because it's
not just Trump in multiple pictures with
left harness Trump said it's okay for
his own personal lawyer to represent Lev
Parnas and Igor Froman here is an email
which we now have where Donald Trump's
lawyer Jay Sekulow rights to another
Trump lawyer John Dowd and says I spoke
to Trump it's okay for you to represent
Parnas and Froman Trump pictured okay
with shared representation but doesn't
know the guy and of course Parnas was
all over the Trump administration here's
another picture with Donald Trump and
another picture with Parnas I think you
get the idea
Kellyanne Conway then went on CNN and
insisted she doesn't know the guy either
at what left or 'no says and what the
documents show and what the president
asked in the summary well the president
does and i say that he did note that
cuomo was talking about what left Parnas
said not whether Kellyanne Conway knows
him and she says I don't know him and
here is a picture of Kelly Ann with Lev
Parnas vice president Mike Pence ich
doing a similar denial saying I don't
know the guy of course there are
pictures of them together as well but
the real point with pence is that Lev
Parnas is alleging that pence knew what
was being done in Ukraine and whether
Mike Pence does or doesn't know Lev
Parnas is not relevant to whether Mike
Pence knew what was being done with
Ukraine and of course every indication
every allegation is that he did one more
cherry on top here there's been this
very corrupt relationship between Donald
Trump and a woman named Pam Bondi for
many years Pam Bondi is the former
attorney general of Florida who was
starting to investigate Trump University
that total scam sham money MIT money
grab that Donald Trump participated in
years ago called Trump University and
Pam Bondi abruptly stopped investigating
Trump University around the same time
that Donald Trump donated $25,000 to her
campaign for re-election Pam Bondi just
so happens has recently joined Donald
Trump's defense team we'll get to more
about that later and here's a picture of
her with Lev Parnas this is the guy who
was managing physical surveillance of a
sitting US ambassador and they all know
him so here's the deal they all know him
to some degree the exact degree is not
really important Lev Parnas is and has
been around Trump and the people around
him for a while he has had access he was
doing insane things as a henchman for
Donald Trump's lawyer the idea that
trumpets are excusing a president having
his personal lawyer through private
investigators put an ambassador under
physical surveillance and they are
saying the real problem here is Joe
Biden and hunter Biden and burries ma is
extraordinarily disturbing now
last sort of word of caution here the
left has to be careful about accepting
everything left Parnas as as if it's
true
left participated a lot of dirty work
for Republicans he's now in huge trouble
he's coming out he's telling the truth
he's copping to tons of misdeeds and
will accept it with a skeptical eye it's
similar to when Michael Cohen turned
Donald Trump and all of a sudden there
were people on the Left who said this
guy everything he's saying can be
trusted 100% no he's in huge trouble and
to some degree he probably realizes the
error of his ways in a sense but these
are individuals who for a very long time
while the going was good they kept on
going with no problem whatsoever so it's
important not to immediately think that
a guy with a life of sketchy behavior is
suddenly our best friend because his
back is up against the wall and he's
lawyered up and he's turning on Donald
Trump
I'm sure that much of what left Parnas
is saying is true but let's not make him
into our hero and hang the case against
Donald Trump strictly on what left
Parnas says this rarely works out well
for anybody including Democrats on the
Left we'll continue talking about this
on Instagram excuse me
follow me there at David Pakman followed
the David Pakman show on Instagram at
David Pakman show we'll be back right
after this short break
Trump attorney Rudy Giuliani's indicted
henchman Lev harness said that people
around Trump are going to continue to
deny knowing him and as they continue to
do that he is going to start releasing
documents and audio-visual evidence
confirming that they actually do know
him and so far he's sticking to his
words left' Parnassus attorney leaked a
video showing him hanging out with Mike
Pence and Pence's wife holding her hand
just after Mike Pence insisted he
doesn't know Lev Parnas now there are
caveats here which we will get to but
this is delightful let's take a look at
the video here we will play it without
audio because the video has copy written
music on it and if the YouTube algorithm
were to pick up on me playing someone
else's music we would be immediately
penalized as terrible terrible people
that we are but what you can see in the
video is Lev Parnas holding hands with
Karen pence Mike Pence's wife chatting
with her Mike Pence is next to her
talking to someone else at the table and
the video cuts off and loops as Mike
Pence kind of gets ready to shift over
in the direction of left Parnas now we
don't yet have the full details about
this encounter but of course what we do
know is that all of these people are
lying about not knowing
Parnas and I'll catch you up from the
beginning Donald Trump hired Rudy
Giuliani as his personal attorney one of
the things Rudy Giuliani did was get
ambassador Murray Ivanovitch quote out
of the way for Donald Trump and he
partially did that with the help of two
henchmen left Parnas and Igor Froman
both of whom have since been indicted
Froman not visibly cooperating Parnas
very much cooperating with documents and
files and testimony and recordings for a
while there have been Republicans who
have been insisting we don't know the
guy most recently we had documents
revealed that show left Parnas was
involved in putting physical
surveillance on ambassador Murray
Ivanovich which is absolutely insane for
the henchmen of a president's personal
attorney to be doing and it was also
confirmed that despite congressman Devin
Nunez insisting I have not had no
contact with left Parnas Lev Parnas and
Devin Nunez did communicate by phone
this panicked everybody around Donald
Trump they started scrambling to say
left-left Parnas who who by I don't know
the guy no idea who you're talking about
earlier this week in a video that now
has nearly 200,000 views we showed you
pictures of loved Parnas with everybody
with Donald Trump with Jared Kushner
with Ivanka Trump Kellyanne Conway Mike
Pence Eric Trump Don Jr the whole gang
now once again even talking to Mike
Pence and Karen pence at some kind of
event it's not proof that they were
friends with Lev Parnas but there's
clearly recognition here Parnassus
holding hands with Karen pence this is
not a perfunctory hi nice to meet you
that sometimes happens at fundraisers or
other events they know each other so
here's the deal with Parnas he's been
indicted he's been charged with crimes
he's a henchman who's done lots of dirty
work for Rudy Giuliani and likely for
others we should not put our unmitigated
trust with a guy who is now back against
the wall and desperate to do whatever he
can to get out of trouble but Parnas is
doing what he said he would do he says
he has the goods and that he would
release them he's doing it it's an
absolute pleasure to
him releasing exhibit after exhibit of
evidence linking himself to the people
who continue to claim they just have no
idea who this guy is Mike Pence is a
liar and I thought that these
dominionist evangelical Christians like
Mike Pence aren't they not supposed to
lie or is it okay to lie if you can
justify it somehow and say well the the
the ends justify the means here or
something like that
Pence is lying they're all lying and I
hope left Parnas continues to one little
a bit at a time exposed that they know
him now the separate question of course
is what's going to happen in the Senate
impeachment trial we talked about this
yesterday we talked about it a little
bit at the top of the show today
Republicans in the White House are
desperate to prevent left Parnas from
testifying at all with john bolton it
seems as though they're recognizing he
probably will testify and maybe they can
get it to happen behind closed doors
with left Parnas they are going to argue
that he is not a material witness that
what he knows and what he would testify
to would not materially affect the
outcome or understanding of the facts
and evidence by the jurors in this case
100 senators that's obvious BS this guy
clearly has the goods and he should
testify and we'll see if Democrats can
force it to happen because Democrats are
up against a Republican majority intent
on preventing it from happening we'll
see good for live partners for
continuing to release this stuff if you
watched Donald Trump's impeachment trial
day three yesterday on Fox News you
might not have heard much about this
because they ran a lot of the
proceedings on mute running my pillow
commercials over the impeachment
proceedings or you had hosts talking
over the proceedings talking about how
hunter Biden is really what this
impeachment trial should be about but
that did not stop Donald Trump from
absolutely losing his mind and tweeting
a record for him 141 times in one day
that was only up until 6:00 p.m. and
then it continued I've told you before
when Donald Trump seemingly spends the
entire day doing nothing but tweeting
sometimes dozens of tweets once I think
he got into the 80s or 90s we didn't see
that much Twitter activity from Donald
Trump on Tuesday but I'm now realizing
that was
because he was still at the World
Economic Forum in Davos Switzerland and
then travelling back eventually
yesterday he had more time back in
Washington DC and I think sitting on Air
Force One and he broke his own personal
record for tweets and retweets in a
single day tweeting 141 times by 6:00
p.m. Eastern continuing into the night
and this morning
most of the tweets are either tweets or
retweets of extremist Republican quotes
videos and statements sometimes just
absolute nonsense conspiracy theories
from Donald Trump
the tweets include Trump's and his
friends attacks on the house impeachment
managers who sort of are the prosecutors
in the impeachment trial including of
course a favorite target of Trump's is
extreme anger at Adam Schiff Trump this
morning including a mostly capitalized
tirade of course a hallmark of Trump is
tweets both Trump and his supporters are
when you get set up to tweet you turn
caps lock on and you turn spellcheck off
that's how if you're getting yourself
set up to tweet Trump is stuff you've
got a disable spellcheck and enable caps
lock this morning Donald Trump sang
Attorney General's oh I mean it's it's
attorneys general I I know that Trump
doesn't Attorney General's from 21
states are urging the Senate to reject
capital I impeachment they say the
articles have legal and factual problems
and the Democrats case sets a dangerous
historical precedent missing an
apostrophe random capitalization and
then now caps lock engaged buckle in
folks all caps even an unsuccessful
effort to impeach the president
undermines the integrity of the 20/20
election because it weapon eise's a
process that should only be initiated in
exceedingly rare circumstances and
should never be used for partisan
purposes the Democrats are trying hard
to damage Republicans prior to the
capital e election I'm sweating now
here's what you need to understand one
41 tweets by 6:00 p.m. if he started at
midnight
that's 18 hours ok 141 tweets in 18
hours is 8 tweets per hour
that's one tweet every seven and a half
minutes but that's if he's not sleeping
at all and just tweeting for 18 hours
straight if we assume that Trump tweeted
141 times starting at you know 5:00 a.m.
maybe which sounds insane to you or I
but but you know to you or me
between 5 a.m. and 6 p.m. a hundred and
forty one tweets that's eleven tweets
per hour meaning a tweet every five and
a half minutes it's the President of the
United States he's sending out a tweeter
retweet every five minutes for an entire
workday this amount of tweeting isn't
normal for anyone if I look at my
Twitter feed and I see someone at
messaged me five times in an hour
I immediately mute them I don't have
time for this nonsense Trump is tweeting
141 times in a day and it's funny in a
way to see him so triggered on Twitter
it is funny to see Donald Trump at these
world events like Davos as the guy none
of the other world leaders really want
to talk to the idea of the adults are
meeting about important things and Trump
is on his phone tweeting that's a
hilarious image but it's really bad it's
an embarrassment
it's a laughingstock for the United
States I don't even have time to read a
hundred and forty-one tweets in a day
and Donald Trump is sending out a
hundred and forty one tweets and
retweets I expect that this is going to
get even worse once the Republicans take
over their defense of Donald Trump in
the Senate and the reason why is that a
lot of Donald Trump Donald Trump's
Twitter activity is retweeting videos
that are people saying nice things about
him or defending him once his lawyers
Pat Cipollone II and Jay Sekulow once
they take over I think Donald Trump
could potentially even break his own
record of 141 tweets and retweets in a
single day Germany has confirmed that
when the Iran Fiasco was going down
Donald Trump threatened Europe with an
absolutely bonkers 25% tariff
on European cars and the goal of this
was to force Europe to start proceedings
against Iran for violating the nuclear
deal which of course they only decided
to do after Donald Trump already had
pulled the United States from that deal
without Iran having violated it in any
way and this really is going to require
sort of a multi-level analysis to unwind
every absolutely ridiculous and
embarrassing aspect of this so at first
this was merely an allegation by the
supposedly fake news Amazon Jeff Bezos
Washington Post and it just so happens
that it's been confirmed as really good
reporting the claim in the Washington
Post was that Donald Trump secretly
warned France and Germany and the United
Kingdom that the United States would
impose a 25% tariff on European cars if
those countries if Europe didn't trigger
the dispute settlement process contained
in the Iran nuclear agreement the German
Defense Minister Anna gret cramp
Karen Bauer said in London that quote
the this expression or threat as you
will does exist it was indeed a threat
that Donald Trump made trumpets are
pretending that everything's fine and
they're actually defending Donald Trump
saying it worked because Europe
reportedly is now triggering the dispute
mechanism contained in that deal except
that every European country is saying
that they had already made that decision
before Donald Trump issued this threat
and it had nothing to do with Donald
Trump's threat whatsoever so there's a
few stories here and I want to take time
to go through each of them first of all
it is Donald Trump who ruined the Iran
nuclear deal Iran is now admitting
they're enriching uranium beyond the
limits of the 2015 deal and why wouldn't
they it's the correct game theory move
if you game this out Trump bails on the
deal starting to enrich uranium gives
them more negotiation leverage in the
future and again it's Donald Trump who
bailed on the deal anyway Donald Trump
then assassinating the Iranian codes
leader Kasim Soleimani
cemented Iran's decision to scale up
nuclear development number two Trump is
wildly and brazenly threatening
our allies with leverage that he
actually doesn't have here that's what's
really important to understand he
doesn't have the leverage as he is
increasingly the laughingstock
geopolitically and of European US
foreign policy and the number three and
this is really important why would
anyone get into any agreement with the
United States in good faith when Donald
Trump sometimes backs out of deals even
when the other country has stuck to its
part has done its its part to stay in
the deal to stay in compliance with the
deal and otherwise will randomly
threaten tariffs for unrelated requests
if you're another country and the US
says let's do a deal let's do a trade
deal let's do a nuclear deal that let's
do a joint defense deal whatever but
then the next president comes into the
United States Oval Office says you know
I didn't like what that last person did
and cancels the deal
why do you take deal seriously why do
you even get into deals in the first
place when you have all sorts of deals
with the United States and then the
United States randomly threatens you
with the 25 percent tariff because they
want you to persecute another country
why even bother why would you see the
United States as a credible participant
in deals you wouldn't and the United
States increasingly is not seen as
credible this is how little kids work
and even little kids there's actually
been interesting studies done where
little kids seem to have a very they
have a sense of fairness that I don't
want to say is innate but very early on
in childhood they exhibit a sense of
understanding of what fairness means
they seem to exhibit more of that sense
than Donald Trump seems to exhibit and
then never mind that because once again
Donald Trump is threatening to punish
Europe with tariffs whose cost would not
be borne by Europe the cost would be
born here in the United States notice by
the way that for Donald Trump tariffs
are Trump's hammer and so everything
looks like a nail it's the only tool
Trump has to use an analogy someone told
Donald Trump about tariffs early on in
his campaign remember when he was
running on I understand trade only I can
fix it and tariffs are the only tool
that Donald Trump has and he threatens
to use that tool everywhere like a
hammer would be used everything looking
like a nail when that's the only tool
that you have whether it's with China
for economic reasons whether it's with
Europe here for foreign policy reasons I
guess tariffs and maybe the occasional
bomb or assassination better said are
the tools that Donald Trump has it's all
backwards it's it's completely farcical
universe that we're living in Trump
virus violates the Iran nuclear deal
sanctions Iran threatens Europe to get
them to do more to Iran Europe wants no
part of the bigger picture even though
on the mechanism they had already
decided to trigger that and we once
again are the laughingstock with the
leaders of other countries talking among
themselves about did you see this crazy
thing that Donald Trump did as this is
business as usual now in the United
States it's an embarrassing moment to be
led by the person that is in the Oval
Office now hopefully we can get back to
a more sort of rational and thoughtful
approach to these issues after Donald
Trump is gone but removing Donald Trump
is merely step one in this process and
you know the early in Trump's presidency
I would say a lot of the things that
he's doing can be very quickly undone a
lot of these symbolic executive orders
can be immediately canceled by the next
president some of the policy stuff can
be pretty quickly undone by the next
president we are now in the realm of
this stuff will take a long time to fix
removing Trump is only one part of it
we're talking of course of the
relationships with other countries that
Donald Trump has ruined and the
credibility that's been lost behind the
scenes we might think well you just
change the president and all that stuff
gets fixed no because there's a
trickle-down effect from Trump to the
diplomatic relationships where a lot of
the foreign policy is actually done a
lot of the foreign pop by the time Trump
talks to another world leader a lot of
the negotiation and the foreign policy
work has been done by the diplomats the
diplomats from the State Department and
the diplomats from other countries the
relationships that Donald Trump is
ruining trickle down and effect apply
matic relations at many levels and it's
going to take a very long time for that
to be undone and fixed even when Donald
Trump is gone I won't go into this again
because
we've talked about it before but then
you've got judges in the judiciary it
continues I mean even now while we are
looking at the impeachment Senate trial
Donald Trump looking at making bribery
legal I'll talk about that later on in
the show Donald Trump calling his
generals dopes and babies I'll talk
about that later we're talking about all
of these big embarrassments meanwhile
and we're continuing to cover it the
judges continue to be too B's just swept
in often to lifetime positions certainly
to affect American jurisprudence for
decades to come and that is not going
that's not even an issue of we've got to
get Trump out to undo it it's we've got
to get Trump out and then we need to
wait a long time for these folks to
retire or die and then we are going to
have another shot at filling a lot of
these judge judgeship so it's a disaster
we are covering it we'll continue to
cover it but importantly step one is an
important one removing Donald Trump from
office but it is only step one is what I
want to convey to you today the
explosive and embarrassing stories about
Donald Trump contained in the new book
that is coming out today I believe
continue to flow and they are truly the
stuff of Horrors it is now alleged that
Donald Trump visibly struggled to read a
passage from the Constitution while he
was being filmed for a documentary and
then flew into a rage during which he
blamed other people in the room and the
film crew for crinkling a peek crinkling
a piece of paper crinkling I like that
blamed everybody in the room for Trump's
inability to read we've been covering
Trump's difficulty reading for a long
time of course our video Trump fails
basic literacy test now with more than
3.3 million views on YouTube a real
classic so this is a stunning excerpt
from the book a very stable genius we
looked at an excerpt yesterday the book
is by Washington Post reporters Phillip
Rucker and Carol lennick and the excerpt
reads quote with LED lights on stilts in
front of him Trump took his seat you're
lucky you got the easy part
Pelosi told him cheerfully this is Nancy
Pelosi's daughter who's the filmmaker it
gets complicated after this but the
president stumbled trying to get out the
words in the arcane stilted form the
founding fathers had written Trump group
irritated it's very hard to do because
of the language here Trump told the crew
it's very hard to get through that whole
thing without a stumble he added it's
like a different language right
the cameraman tried to calm Trump
telling him it was no big deal to take a
moment and start over Trump tried again
but again remarked it's like a foreign
language this is the Constitution by the
way which he claims to so much
understand he feels as though it's
written in a different language they go
on to write in the book quote every time
he stumbled he manufactured something to
blame people another person in the room
recalled he never said sorry I'm messing
up other people would screw up and say
oh I'm sorry they would be self-effacing
he was making up excuses and saying
there were distracting sounds he was
definitely blaming everyone for his
inability to get through it that was
prickly or childish though stiff he
eventually made it through without any
errors and then again continuing
whatever the reason for Trump's
discomfort with the reading several
watching agreed this much he behaved
like a brooding child short-tempered
brittle and quick to blame mystery
distractions for his mistakes I didn't
expect this but I felt sorry for him
another witness said when vice president
Pence is reading it when former Vice
President Dick Cheney is reading it I
knew they knew the Constitution and I
thought before he got this job he really
should have read it so this is of course
denied constantly by trumpets they say
Trump's reading is fine clearly it's not
I mean completely unrelated sources of
all kinds that are observing Donald
Trump behind the scenes notice Trump
really struggles to read it's okay just
admit it struggling to read doesn't mean
you're stupid or a bad person or that
your political ideas are bad or anything
it just means he struggles to read the
question becomes why does he so acutely
struggle to read is he merely dyslexic
is the struggling to read part of a
broader cognitive decline did he always
struggle to read or did he have a period
where he did not is there some other
explanation this is not anything to joke
about if you had a 73 year-old in your
family that suddenly had trouble reading
you would want to figure out what
going on you wouldn't pretend nothing's
going on and yet that is exactly what
the most committed trumpets insist on
doing here is more corroboration from
another unrelated source that Donald
Trump you know it's like everybody from
people who worked with the guy on
Saturday Night Live who have nothing to
do with Philip Rucker and Carroll Lennon
of the Washington Post everybody says
when you put something in front of him
and he's got to read it he has trouble
he's on video having trouble let's
figure out what it is that's all doesn't
make his political idea as bad as
political ideas are bad on their own
merits it just means we should know what
is going on and if there is some kind of
cognitive issue taking place here let's
take a quick break
much more coming up on this very busy
Tuesday show some of these stories are
so unbelievable that they actually do
seem like they're not real except they
are and I've talked about the problem
with calling them unbelievable because
it actually creates a sort of disbelief
of things that are all too real and
should horrify us and this is going to
be sort of a short story since it's
still developing I did want to briefly
cover it a top Trump national security
adviser has been reportedly escorted out
of the White House and placed on leave
when it was uncovered that they were
potentially a security risk remember we
were told Donald Trump can be trusted to
hire the right people that he can be
trusted with sensitive information with
information security all of that stuff
Hillary couldn't be trusted except then
Trump is spilling secrets to Russian spy
recruiters in the Oval Office using
unsecured devices that he refuses to
have screened and here appears to have
someone who's a security risk working in
the White House I'm talking about a guy
named Andrew peek Andrew peek is or was
the senior director for European and
Russian affairs at the National Security
Council this is like one of trumps top
Russia advisors he is now on leave and a
security investigation is taking place
Trump had someone on the National
Security Council previously at the State
Department his top person on Russia
involved in all sorts of sensitive areas
and that guy had to be escorted out of
the White House by security the White
House was asked for comment they said we
don't discuss security matters which of
course confirms
that this is a security matter a peek
himself was asked to comment said no
comment so it's not just that Donald
Trump is hiring bad people he's hiring
people who are potentially security
threats that security has to escort out
but the bigger picture issue is that
this is the third time in a year that
this position is vacant never mind other
positions of importance and someone sent
me a funny message because Peake advises
Trump on Russia stuff I got an email
that said hey David do you think Peake
was escorted out because it were was
revealed he's in cahoots with Putin or
do you think he was escorted out because
it was revealed that he's not in cahoots
with Putin and that doesn't work for
Donald Trump
very clever at this point it's all
speculation I actually think that the
entire security threats story might be
false and I'll explain what I mean by
that Andrew peek was an intelligence
officer for a long time he has a
doctorate in International Affairs he
was appointed I believe by David
Petraeus under the Barack Obama
administration it's possible that Trump
missed this guy in the firings of Obama
people and now after the Iranian Fiasco
it's possible Peake started speaking out
saying what you're doing is crazy and
then it was realized by the Trump
administration oh damn how did this guy
slip through the cracks he's got to go
let's escort him out and say that
there's a security investigation going
on I it's mere speculation it's all
crazy I don't know what the final
resolution would be but remember it was
Trump who said I will hire the best
people it was Trump who said the people
around me are just going to be the best
and you know that if you want proof that
trumpets were bamboozled by that line
think back to someone else who tried to
use that same bullet point and was
excoriated Herman Cain Herman Cain is
this pizza entrepreneur who ran for
president for the Republican nomination
I want to say it was 2012 although maybe
it was in 2008 can you imagine if that
was 12 years ago it feels so recent
anyway Herman Cain ran for the
Republican nomination and one of the
things that Herman Cain started saying
early on when he was asked about what
would your policy be in Afghanistan or
you know people were asking policy heavy
questions he would say haven't figured
it out yet but I'm gonna put the best
person in charge of figuring that out
and maybe his followers sort of bought
it but the Republican Party at large did
not buy it and he was completely laughed
at and his campaign fell apart
relatively quick quickly after he said
that on the other hand you've had Donald
Trump effectively saying the same thing
which is that Donald Trump did a better
job of pretending to know about stuff
like trade and health care or whatever
but he also pushed a lot of the same
idea that he was going to hire the best
people he was going to drain the swamp
to put the best people in it's really
the same failed idea that Herman Cain
put forward about I'll figure it out
when I get there and I'll put people in
place who are going to know but with
Donald Trump at work then it actually
succeeded at bamboozling enough of his
followers and even enough Republicans
who said I trust that Donald Trump is
going to take our advice and Trump
sometimes alluded to that by saying hey
you know what I will select justices to
the Supreme Court from a list given to
me by I think it was the Heritage
Foundation I will select judges for
lower court levels from lists that are
generated by this group or that group so
Trump was equally clueless about a lot
of these policy issues but he played the
game about hiring the right people of
course it was a complete and total farce
and he didn't do that and a whole bunch
of his people have been indicted if not
forced out for different reasons many of
them internationally embarrassing at a
private fundraiser at his mar-a-lago
Resort in Florida Donald Trump was
actually asked about his spending and
his explosion of the national debt and
according to people in the room he said
quote who the hell cares about the
budget we're going to have a country now
I've been telling you for years this is
bigger than Trump that the debt and
deficit are a political football that's
all that they are our elected officials
don't really care about debt and deficit
as long as we're going into debt for the
things they want to spend money on and
of course historically even though
Republicans are the so-called deficit
hawks Republicans are the ones who
increase the deficit and thus more
quickly increase the national debt as
well and in fact under Barack Obama
deficit
growth slowed while under Donald Trump
it has absolutely exploded and there is
Trump at his mar-a-lago Resort in
Florida telling donors behind closed
doors who the hell cares about the
budget we're going to have a country the
annual the Trump annual deficit past a
trillion dollars in 2019 and Donald
Trump had promised the opposite Trump
promised that he would get us a surplus
so big that the debt itself would start
shrinking and completely disappear
within eight years now only someone who
is extremely gullible or knows nothing
at all about the debt and deficit would
have even for a second considered that
that might have actually been something
that would happen Donald Trump also
promised that his tax cuts would so
acutely grow the economy that the
deficit would shrink as a result of new
economic productivity that also has not
happened
some Republicans maybe believed him
others didn't but they didn't care
because a lot of them don't actually
care and per MSNBC Donald Trump has now
added two point six trillion dollars to
the national debt in just three years
that's more than Barack Obama added
during his entire second term the truth
is that even Republicans know that the
deficit in and of itself doesn't
actually matter here's a funny video of
reporter Jon Karl asking at a briefing
hey you know Trump said he'd eliminate
the debt what happened with all of that
check out the answer questions one you
mention what the president promised
trying to campaign during the campaign
he also promised that he would eliminate
the national debt within eight years and
as you know at the end of his first year
was a twenty trillion last year in 221
trillion last month twenty two trillion
so what happened to that promise I mean
the president has added historically
large numbers to the national debt
instead of keeping a promise to actually
pay it off look again the last
administration nearly doubled the
national debt and when this president
ran for office he made a commitment to
the American people that he would
attempt to tackle the debt within eight
years this President did that the very
first year that he came to office by
sending forth a budget that balanced
within 10 years so wait
Trump promised to try to do this in
eight
proposed a ridiculous budget that would
have done it in ten and that's
considered an answer to the question and
what matters are really more detailed
questions that don't get asked questions
like what are we spending on that is
growing the deficit are we growing the
deficit because we are paying for health
care or education or is it because we're
paying for weapons as an example are we
growing the deficit or increasing our
national debt in a way that improves the
well-being of the average American or
are we just like going to war with the
countries in the Middle East what
portion of our GDP is the deficit
because remember the raw dollars of
deficit in a vacuum doesn't really tell
us anything we need to compare it to the
size of the economy what kind of deficit
spending has a high multiplier
economically versus a lower economic
multiplier we've talked about that term
before I won't go into it now but again
when we go back to the importance that
Republicans themselves place on this
issue they expose themselves time and
again and reveal that they don't
actually care about the debt and the
deficit beyond it being a tool that they
can use to attack Democrats when it's
convenient this is bigger than Trump it
really is in a way even though Trump
said this behind closed doors and
probably didn't intend for it to become
public Trump is being more honest than
most of them when he says who cares
about the budget when we have a country
in the sense that that means debt and
deficit don't matter as long as we're
doing the things that I want to do and
that the people who are going to vote
for me believe that I should be doing or
want me to do any Republican when
Republicans are in power does not care
about the deficit any Republican when
there is a Democratic president believes
that the out-of-control spending is the
number-one problem and that we can
somehow cut our way to prosperity and a
better middle middle class and a better
functioning economy it's a farce and I
appreciate even if it's behind closed
doors Donald Trump just saying who cares
about it and then of course reminder any
time we talk about this we have to
continue to drill it this repeatedly we
never hear this question asked by
Republicans except for like the
occasional Rand Paul libertarian we
never hear the question but how would we
pay for this war remember when it looked
like we might be going to war with Iran
a couple of weeks ago I think Rand Paul
said something about how much it would
cost although it might have just been
about like his non interventionist stuff
that he was complaining but there's no
questions from Republicans about can we
afford war with Iran what would be the
cost where are we gonna get the money
what about the deficit what about the
debt and yet we hear all the time we
can't afford health insurance we can't
afford free public college we can't
afford to pay for Mature
maternity leave or a paid sick time or
whatever the case may be it is merely a
political football used when it is
convenient don't for a second think that
it is anything other than that